[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les joueurs du Stade de Reims maillot a
manche blanche ont éprouvé une
désagréable surprise à Monaco
contrairement à l'habitude il pleuvait
en effet à torrent dans la principauté
au début du match contre les Monégasques
mais ce n'était pas là la seule surprise
enregistrée par les Rémois 8 minutes de
jeu à peine ils encaissent un premier
but signé douces
réagit très rapidement car elle belle
égalise peu de temps après
[Applaudissements]
et les Rémois vont même prendre le large
un très joli une deux puis Anthony
hakesby un tir de voler comme on envoie
plus souvent en France deux un
après ce petit festival Rémois les
Monégasques veulent prouver que aussi
ils savent jouer au football un très
long centre de kossu numéro 9 une
reprise de Hidalgo Monaco également
il est vrai n'est pas dans un bon jour
en tout cas cette égalisation remet
Monaco en sel et Colona va commettre une
nouvelle erreur les Monégasques jouent
bien il ne pardonne pas les erreurs 3 à
2 pour Monaco
[Applaudissements]
en seconde mi-temps race ne va pas avoir
beaucoup plus de chance l'équipe
tourneront lui manque cependant le tout
petit quelque chose qui devrait lui
permettre de forcer le destin c'est au
contraire Monaco qui flirt avec la
chance 4 à 2
et pour prouver qu'ils n'ont pas
seulement la chance avec eux les
Monégasques sont bien décidés à faire
bonne mesure score final 5 à 2 pour
Monaco c'est juste mais un peu sévère
pour un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à Paris Monseigneur Bertoli a présenté
au nom des 83 chefs de missions les vœux
du corps diplomatique au président de la
République française
une réception parmi les nombreuses
autres qui se sont succédées 10 heures
durant au palais présidentiel
[Musique]
à Londres la nouvelle année sortie de
l'oeuf a déclenché les farandoles de
l'alberto
[Musique]
ce fut bien pi à Trafalgar Square ou
sous la neige les fontaines ont été
prises d'assaut par les noctambules en
mal de bain de minuit ou de 5 heures du
matin
les Londoniens ont bien fait mentir la
réputation de réserves qui s'attache au
tempérament britanniques
c'est une habitude la Joconde vient
encore de faire parler d'elle
monsieur haking un antiquaire de Nice a
conduit les journalistes aux machins
Chanteloup pour leur montrer le tableau
qu'il estimait être le vrai portrait
peint par Léonard de Vinci
ce qui revenait à dire que l'Amérique
admirait un faux ni plus ni moins
[Musique]
des preuves monsieur eking en avait une
définitive l’œil de la Joconde du Louvre
et mou affirmait-il
pic comparer l'oeil de Saint Joconde
mais l'expert italien n'y connaît mieux
formelle la vraie Joconde est à
Washington on peut dire qu'il a évité le
pire entre la France et les États-Unis
d'Amérique
[Musique]
les jeunes vont de plus en plus vite et
ceci n'est pas un compte de fait devenir
à 18 ans une vedette du disque une
vedette plus vendue que la Callas alors
qu'il y a 6 mois elle n'était encore
qu'une timide étudiante en langue
allemande telle est l'aventure vécue par
Françoise Hardy elle rêvait bien sûr des
lauriers d'Elvis Presley mais comment
expliquer ces 270 000 disques vendus la
réponse il faut la chercher chez ses
clients nouveaux que sont les moins de
18 ans qui ont leur mode bien à eux qui
imposent leur goût et leurs vedettes
écoutez-la regardez-les vous comprendrez
promène dans la rue de par deux
tous les garçons et les filles de mon
âge ça veut bien ce que c'est
h et les yeux dans les yeux et la malade
dans la main il s'en vont amoureux sans
peur du lendemain oui mais moi
je vais seul par les rues
lamentais oui mais moi je vais seule car
personne ne m'aime
1113 cubains anti-castriste fait
prisonnier lors de la tentative de
débarquement de 1961 ont été rendus par
Fidel Castro ils ont retrouvé la liberté
à Miami et commencer l'année nouvelle en
famille après 20 mois de détention mais
rarement liberté aura été payé aussi
cher puisqu'il en a coûté aux États-Unis
sous forme de médicaments et aliments
divers une rançon de 47000 dollars par
prisonnier
on comprend que le président Kennedy est
tenu à venir saluer lui-même ses hommes
les prisonniers les plus chers de
l'histoire il tenait aussi à faire le
point devant les anti-castristes et
leurs amis de l'attitude américaine face
au régime cubain une attitude sans
concession ce que la première dame des
États-Unis s'est chargée de traduire en
espagnol
[Applaudissements]
les événements du Katanga sont un sujet
de préoccupation pour le monde entier
qui a vu avec stupeur les troupes des
Nations Unies écraser la résistance
catégorèse avec une vigueur inattendue
69 gisais dans les décombres de
l'hôpital de l'Union Minière après les
violents combats qui opposèrent à
Lubumbashi Ethiopien et catégorie
[Musique]
djembé comptait sur ses gendarmes et ses
troupes d'élite pour défendre pieds à
pied le territoire qu'il contrôlait mais
tout son dispositif militaire semble
s'être soudainement effondré il ne lui
restait plus qu'à pratiquer la politique
de la terre brûlée et en détruisant tous
les ouvrages d'art essayer de retarder
l’avance des troupes de l'ONU avant
aussi rapide qu'elle semblait
embarrasser le secrétaire général de
l'ONU monsieur tante
[Musique]
les mercenaires européens qui
encadraient la gendarmerie kapenguez ont
été fait prisonniers
[Musique]
table des civils
sur les routes sur les pistes hommes
femmes et enfants s'acheminaient vers la
Rhodésie voisine fuyant les horreurs de
la guerre
[Musique]
Hong Kong un port riche au frontières de
demande et tout autour des barraques
entassés des bidons vides trio une
capitale ultramodern avec des buildings
et une route qui dessine son tracé
futuriste sous un bidonville c'est un
phénomène général international New York
ou Moscou les bidonvilles n'épargnaient
aucune capitale Paris pas plus que les
autres et voici un document tourné en
toute objectivité malgré les difficultés
qu'on peut imaginer sur cette plaie des
grandes cités à Nanterre ou à La
Courneuve les bidons villes ressemblent
à ceux de toutes les latitudes il se
ressemblent tous quelques planches mâles
jointes des toits fait de n'importe quoi
sur un terrain vague des hommes venus en
masse travailler dans la région
parisienne on fait naître ces cités
misérables africains du Nord portugais
espagnol et aussi des Français
si logite est précaire du moins il est
bon marché et dans ce souci d'économie
on peut trouver une des raisons d'être
du bidonville une seule fontaine pour
toute la triste agglomération c'est le
rendez-vous des enfants l'accord vedo
remplace souvent les codes
on vit entre soi des commerçants ont ici
leurs éventaires à la mesure et à
l'image de l'habitat
[Musique]
heure du marché ressemble à toutes les
heures de marché mais on est dans un
autre univers non l'univers de la misère
car la plupart de ces hommes ont un
emploi mais un univers de hasard de
passage insoupçonnable et souvent
insoupçonné
[Musique]
pas de services de nettoyage les chiens
s'en occupent
mais rien n'est redoutable comme l'hiver
lorsqu'ils cerne ses constructions
chances
il n'y a guère que le poil de fonte de
l'épicerie buvette qui produit quelque
chaleur chaleur humaine aussi car c'est
là qu'on retrouve d'autres hommes
parlant la même langue à l'heure de la
détente
ailleurs il faut accumuler les vêtements
pour lutter contre ce froid que n'arrive
pas à combattre la flamme du foyer
ainsi vivent dans les conditions de la
misère des centaines de familles aux
portes de la grande ville
insouciant des enfants meubles se
décorent sans espoir de leur jeu sans
fin
[Musique]
comment résoudre le problème
continuellement méthodiquement les
constructions nouvelles grignotent les
bidonvilles
[Musique]
les bulldozers à date ici et là l'une de
ces cités de planches de parpaing et de
tôle pour laisser la place à des
habitations dignes de ce nom
seul va être un bidonville
la construction s'efforce de faire face
aux flux des nouveaux venus mais il ne
suffit pas de remplacer un bidonville
s'il doit en être un autre un peu plus
loin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]